joe ryan brought his silver medal to
target field showing it around and uh
he'll build up your neck muscles that
that thing's pretty happy
oh yeah
it's a big one well congratulations on
the silver medal that you won in the
tokyo olympics pitched in two games
including the middle game that got the
us into the gold medal game
congratulations charlie barnes still
looking for that first win high earned
run average but throw those numbers out
the winner is just his third start he's
got plenty of foundation in him he's
pitched some in the minor leagues but
again the fastball will not touch 90
he's going to rely on finesse and
control and of course one of the
greatest pitchers in baseball history
did that a guy named whitey four
because now all of a sudden it's three
and two and a change-up got him yeah
nice job so long and bad after jumping
out ahead 0-2 but eventually a strikeout
actually actually that ball had a little
like slider spin to it but it backed up
got by with it nice hand again for
nelson cruz
bouncer left side
ostidio catches spins and on target
crews retired two away so two down and
that'll bring up austin meadows
lifted
near third base a long run
and ostidio gets there and finishes off
a one two three first inning for charlie
barr for the tampa bay rays right-hander
luis patino making his ninth start of
the season you want to see pitino
attacking pitching aggressively with
confidence in his stuff so first and
second a pair of walks donaldson will
come to the plate
scalded to left field kepler gonna be
waved around by tony diaz and the throw
lobbed back to the infield and donaldson
drives in the game's first run yeah
middle end right where josh likes it hit
it hard didn't get it elevated for a
home run but hit solidly max hesitated
for just a second there like he didn't
know now he gets going full speed kind
of surprised meadows didn't really fire
the ball in from left field big rbi spot
now for larning three out there with one
out
back to the mound
a low throw
one but not two
so larnick will drive in a run staying
out of the double play
and petino if he
maybe had a chance to rethink that might
have come home you have to as a pitcher
it doesn't take a lot of skill takes
anticipation so
when you're out there you say you know
if the ball is sent to me i'm going home
and you're right
when he feels that if he just pivots the
play is at home he probably gets a
double play and he's out of the inning
but you could see him hesitate he looked
at first then he looked at second and
made a bad throw
the two across and two out there things
happen quickly on the field and you have
to think quickly six up six down now a
pair of hits and the tying runs at
second with nobody out crown ball
towards first to no has it runner coming
to the plate to throw from snow on
target
even with a double clutch is able to
fire home and get zanino at the plate
yeah and a nice tag now that catchers
used that one-handed glove johnny bench
started to use it years ago they can use
it just like a first baseman's glove and
make that
sweet tag nice decision by
snow and this dixon even with a double
clutch strong enough
got the runner and he saves a run there
oh that was a great play underrated
though that tag for the catcher on that
play is very difficult mitch did a nice
job here's a rosarena they call him the
cuban rocket
big strikeout by barge he came back
inside to clip the corner two down crews
with two down three and two um oh
wow there we go yeah singles opened up
the inning but it's a scoreless third
what an escape act from charlie barnes
kepler will be moving from second
polanco will be often motoring from
first base hole shift on for donaldson
huge opportunity for the twins who lead
two-nothing it would be great to break
it open right here
drill to the left-field corner donaldson
delivers kepler will score polanco on
his heels and donaldson drives him too
with a double well you gotta hope he
makes a mistake and you see zazino's
target and the pitch comes up and in
right where josh donaldson likes it ball
inside and he cashes it in all those
base on balls two of them scored on the
first now two more here in the fourth
you take into account who he's facing
the injuries he's still dealing with
that was a big time impact mike zenino
stepping in he extended his hitting
streak to eight with a lead off base hit
in the third
that's a long one to left back into deep
left field and gone
home run for mike cenino that's number
25. so the raids are on the board
connects here in the fifth cenino
extending his hitting strength with a
single in the third home run for the
fourth consecutive game for mike zenino
25 on the year and here it is hanging
change change-up that's a big pitch for
barnes that one he got underneath the
left-hander the newest addition to the
ray's bullpen adam conley
face scarver
and strike three he gets the call
on that pitch down around the knees
garber caught looking for the second
time yeah the off speed pitch looked
like a changeup down in the zone close
enough
and there's a chase on 97 up he may have
done it right there that pitch wasn't
even close and he still gets the swing
so meadows will head to first base with
bronco coming to the plate
bronco swings and hits one deep to right
that one is going to get out of here
home run over the porch and right his
sixth home run of the year and suddenly
the rays are down by only a run first
pitch and franco turned on it in a hurry
right there that ball up and in and
wander franco with a quick bat right
there barrel it and i'll tell you a game
where the rays have been quiet it's felt
like it has been just minnesota has
owned this thing four to three with some
good amount of baseball left the bases
are loaded with one out and now randy
arose arena and a 2-2 pitch again
he taps it third base side going to be a
tough play at first safe there a run
scores so the rays will tie this game
and the bases are still loaded the
rosarito reaching on an infield hit
arrives came in from third and had the
one possible play
luke lowe scores
a swinging bunt basically swinging
a rise i mean that that's it that has to
be a perfect throw on the run and just
not able to get all the way across his
body so the ball sails on him a little
bit snow has to come off the bag
chocolate the sixth appearance than a
raised uniform snow will be the hitter
and there's a cut in the miss so he gets
a big strikeout of snow right there
cautious with him and strikes him out
got him with that slider down and away
and that pitch has not been you know
that's a big pitch for sagua jake cave
is oh for three we're in the bottom of
the eighth
oh that is a strike call on the outside
corner he got 95 up there and just on
that edge lolden to sleep with all the
sliders now simmons who entered as a
pinch runner in the sixth inning
little tapper to the mound
the toss to first in time to take care
of simmons max kepler who has seven
walk-off hits a couple of home runs he's
the guy the twins have relied on to get
a lot of their biggest hits and he'll
lead off the ninth inning
to left field slashing to the corner and
kepler has another opposite field extra
base hit the ball gets away from meadows
kepler flying to third base with a lead
off triple
here's a double and an error polanco the
batter going one a high drive
oh what a catch and kepler will trot
home with a winning run and it's a
sacrifice fly and a game-winner for
horry polanco